>>> IN THE HEALTH LEAD, ALMOST
TWO YEARS INTO THE PANDEMIC AND
GERMANY RECORDED ITS HIGHEST
COVID INFECTION RATE EVER.
CASES ARE SO HIGH IN EUROPE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
CONSIDERS THE REGION AN
EPICENTER OF SPREAD.
NOW DESPITE ALL THAT, TODAY THE
UNITED STATES IS LOOSENING
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS AND
LEGISLATE FULLY VACCINATED
TRAVELERS FROM 33 COUNTRIES,
INCLUDING MUCH OF EUROPE, COME
ON IN.
CNN'S MELISSA BELL IS IN PARIS
WHERE SOME OF THE FIRST FLIGHTS
ORIGINATED TODAY.
>> THE BAGS ARE PACKED AND READY
TO GO.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MORE THAN
A YEAR AND A HALF, THE UNITED
STATES FINALLY OPENING ITS
BORDERS TO FOREIGN VACCINATED
TRAVELERS.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IN CHARLE de
GAULLE AIRPORT IN THE 2E
TERMINAL IS A MUCH BUSIER
TERMINAL THAN I'VE SEEN IN A
LONG TIME.
AND A LOT MORE FLIGHTS UP ON THE
BOARDS TO ATLANTA, LOS ANGELES,
NEW YORK, MIAMI AND SOME PRETTY
EXCITED TRAVELERS.
>> WE ARE HAPPY BECAUSE OF THE
WEATHER, ESPECIALLY.
WE CAN --
I HOPE IT CONTINUES BECAUSE WE
HESITATE ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
FOURTH WAVE WAS UPCOMING AND I
DON'T KNOW IF BORDERS WILL BE
CLOSED AGAIN ONE TIME.
>> Reporter: THAT NEW WAVE OF
INFECTIONS HAS ALREADY ARRIVED
IN EUROPE CAUSING THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO SOUND THE
ALARM LATE LAST WEEK.
>> CUMULATIVELY, THERE ARE NOW
MORE REPORTED CASES, 78 MILLION,
IN THE EUROPEAN REGION THAN IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA, THE EASTERN
MEDITERRANEAN, THE WESTERN
PACIFIC AND AFRICA COMBINED.
WE ARE ONCE AGAIN AT AN
EPICENTER.
>> Reporter: THE REASON FOR THE
EUROPEAN SURGE?
LIKELY A COMBINATION OF FACTORS,
INCLUDING LOW OR LAGGING VACCINE
RATES IN EASTERN EUROPE, THE
CIRCULATION OF A NEW SUBVARIANT
OF THE HIGHLY TRANSMISSIBLE
DELTA VARIANT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, ONE THAT'S
ESTIMATED TO BE EVEN MORE
CONTAGIOUS.
COLDER TEMPERATURES PUSHING MORE
ACTIVITIES INDOORS, WANING
IMMUNITY FROM EARLY COVID
INOCULATIONS AND INFECTIONS, AS
WELL AS FATIGUE AND COMPLACENCY
SURROUNDING PROTECTIVE MEASURES
LIKE MASK WEARING AND CAREFUL
HAND WASHING.
THE END RESULT, A STARTLING
STATISTIC.
IN THE LAST FOUR WEEKS ALONE,
EUROPE HAS REGISTERED MORE THAN
A 55% RISE IN NEW COVID-19
CASES.
BUT SO FAR THOSE NUMBERS NOT
CAUSING A CHANGE OF COURSE IN
THE U.S. DECISION TO REOPEN ITS
BORDERS.
OR DAMPENING THE EXCITEMENT OF
THESE TRAVELERS.
>> JUST AMAZING, ISN'T IT?
>> IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
WAITING.
>> JAKE, THIS COMES, OF COURSE,
AT A TIME WHEN A BELEAGUERED
TRAVEL INDUSTRY NEEDED A BOOST.
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN LOST BY THE AMERICAN
TRAVEL INDUSTRY ALONE.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED AIRLINES
WHO SAID ALREADY AND WITHIN DAYS
OF THAT ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
REOPENING OF THE AMERICAN
BORDERS ITS SEEN ITS HIGHEST
LEVEL OF TRANSATLANTIC BOOKINGS
SINCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
BACK ABOVE 2019 LEVELS.
A REMARKABLE BOOST.
THE QUESTION IS, JAKE, HOW LONG
THAT'S GOING TO LAST.
>> MELISSA BELL.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN DR.
SANJAY GUPTA.
LET'S TAKE STOCK OF THIS
DECISION BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
COVID CASES IN EUROPE HAVE BEEN
GOING UP.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY AT AN
ALARMING RATE FOR WEEKS NOW.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS REOPENING
BORDERS TO INTERNATIONAL
TRAVELERS, AS LONG AS THEY'VE
BEEN VACCINATED.
IS THAT FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE,
THE DATA DOESN'T SEEM, FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW, TO BACK UP THIS
DECISION.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE THING
ABOUT IT IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN THE
UNITED STATES AND EUROPE
COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN GOING UP
THERE.
BUT WHEN YOU DRILL DOWN ON THAT,
IT'S PRIMARILY ALONG
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE.
SO, YOU KNOW, AS MELISSA WAS
DESCRIBING, THESE TRAVEL
REQUIREMENTS ARE THE PEOPLE HAVE
TO BE VACCINATED AND THEY ALSO
HAVE TO SHOW PROOF OF A NEGATIVE
TEST AS WELL.
I THINK WHEN YOU ADD THOSE TWO
LAYERS IN, THAT OFFERS
SIGNIFICANT PROTECTION.
WHERE WE'RE SEEING NUMBERS GO
UP, WHETHER IT'S IN POCKETS IN
THE UNITED STATES OR, AS YOU SAW
THERE IN EUROPE, IT'S STILL
PRIMARILY AMONG THE
UNVACCINATED.
AS MUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT
BOOSTERS AND ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS, THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM.
WITH THOSE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS, I THINK IT'S MUCH
SAFER, OBVIOUSLY, TO LET PEOPLE
IN.
>> HERE IN THE U.S., THERE'S
THIS ALARMING NEW POLL GET TOING
AT THE SPREAD OF DISINFORMATION
AND MISINFORMATION.
THEY HEARD AT LEAST ONE COVID
MYTH.
78% OF THEM EITHER BELIEVE THE
FALSE STATEMENT OR WEREN'T SURE
IF IT WAS TRUE OR FALSE.
SOME OF THESE MYTHS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS EXAGGERATING THE
NUMBER OF COVID DEATHS OR THAT
VACCINES CAN CAUSE INFERTILITY
OR THE VACCINES CONTAIN A
MICROCHIP OR VACCINES CAN CHANGE
YOUR DNA.
ALL OF THIS FALSE.
THIS ISN'T AN OLD SURVEY.
THIS POLL WRAPPED UP JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO.
DOES IT FEEL LIKE PEOPLE HAVE
LARGELY GIVEN UP ON TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S REAL AND
WHAT'S NOT?
>> IT MAY FEEL THAT WAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE NOT GIVEN
UP.
I HAVEN'T GIVEN UP.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE TRYING TO REACH INTO
COMMUNITIES WHERE A LOT OF THAT
MISINFORMATION IS BEING SPREAD.
I REMEMBER TALKING TO DR. PETER
HOTEZ ABOUT THIS WHO HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH MISINFORMATION
ABOUT VACCINES LONG BEFORE THIS
PANDEMIC.
THERE WAS A SENSE YEARS AGO,
LOOK, DON'T GIVE IT MORE FUEL.
DON'T TRY AND RISE -- RAISE THIS
MISINFORMATION TO LEVELS WHERE
IT SPREADS MORE EASILY.
THOSE DAYS HAVE PASSED.
THE INFORMATION --
MISINFORMATION TRAVELS FASTER
SOMETIMES THAN THE VIRUS ITSELF.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO SPEAK UP MORE THAN
EVER.
WHAT THEY FIND, JAKE, AS PART OF
THESE SURVEYS, IS THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRUSTED THE MOST
ARE PEOPLE WITHIN PEOPLE'S OWN
SOCIAL CIRCLES.
IF YOU ARE SUDOMEONE WHO HAS DO
THE HOMEWORK AND TALKS ABOUT IT
WITH FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES,
THAT MAKES THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE.
>> THEY HAD UNTIL THIS HOUR TO
REPLY TO A DEADLINE TO GET
VACCINATED BY JANUARY 4th.
WHAT MIGHT BE THE MEDICAL IMPACT
IF A COURT SAYS THIS MANDATE
CANNOT BE IMPLEMENTED?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE
ABOUT 58% VACCINATED.
WE'RE GOING INTO THE WINTER
MONTHS.
IT'S COOLER, DRIER.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE INDOORS
CLUSTERING TOGETHER MORE SO THAN
THEY HAVE IN A LONG TIME.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THE RISK
AND THE VACCINES CAN HELP REALLY
REDUCE THAT RISK QUITE A BIT.
WE KNOW THESE MANDATES, THEY'RE
NOT PALATABLE IN A LOT OF
SECTORS, BUT THEY WORK.
UNITED AIRLINES IN AUGUST WERE
ABOUT 59% OF THE WORKFORCE
VACCINATED.
NOW CLOSER TO 99%.
LET ME SHOW YOU AMONG HEALTH
CARE WORKERS.
QUICKLY, THE MISINFORMATION WE
TALKED TO CAN APPLY TO HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AS WELL.
IT LOOKED AT FLU OVERALL, THEY
SAY OVERALL, ABOUT 80%
VACCINATED.
BUT LOOK AT THE PLACES WHERE
THERE'S MANDATES VERSUS NOT.
SO THESE ARE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WHO ARE TAKING CARE